wie ich es lebe mehr zum königer schaffe
oder schaffe mir zum volk wissen können
leben
auf die frage welche ideen die antworten
macht auch glück ich glaube dass ich es
schaffe das ist ja so dass die situation
angeht muss es mehr so viel wert dass
man zum trinken und macht ist dass er
als haben dann aber sind wenn es etwas
bringt er bemerkte dass mir sehe
teamplayer sind und mit dem trainer
zusammen schafft aber ich liebe das dass
ich meinen tag gestalten denn ich muss
mir eigentlich chefin bin ausser man
schon immer große wertschätzung
[Applaus]
ich bin da im café tante in basel das
tor der streit durch geschäftsführer
weil macht ihr eigenes ding aber
glücklich einfach nur glücklich wer hier
lebt das gas gabrisch lied vom portier
wurde
was macht nur das café ist und
eigentlich geht es da jetzt um den
kaffee serviert wird bei der strafe was
unternehmer partie aus äthiopien der
schweiz vertrieben und die teams die ein
sehr spezielles verhältnis zu glauben
diese nochmals 15 stunden in der woche
muss lange
die wohnung von michael und maritim und
ihren beiden kindern beschäftigt ihre
firma direct coffee büro sitzungszimmer
eigentlich so dass jetzt das wohnzimmer
mit küche
dann haben wir eine hohe zimmer und ein
spielzimmer sagen dass das hier auch
büro ja ja das ist unser büro also ich
arbeite immer am esstisch und michael
arbeitet im bücherregal stehen arbeitet
arbeit und freizeit der autark der tools
kennt diese unterscheidung kam dann wie
gelesen sie arbeiten das ist alltag bei
ihnen können wir unser alltag so gestalt
sondern dass wir viel zeit kinder haben
beide male günstig und dann sehr
konzentriert arbeiten können wenn die
kinder schlafen wenn ich ja draußen
gesehen wieder andere vielleicht oder so
was funktioniert er ja schon mal tage
das unternehmer ehepaar arbeitet sehr
viel weniger raus in seinem früheren
leben als journalistin und
unternehmensberater und sie seien
trotzdem produktlieferung aus damals was
wir meinen ist damit dass wir richtig
konzentriert am computer zum beispiel
arbeiten dass es 15 stunden ungefähr
begrenzt und was aber natürlich ganz
viel arbeit ist ist zum beispiel wenn
ich jetzt die website die texte schreibe
mir zu überlegen was da rein kommt und
das kann ich natürlich auch vom computer
machen und früher hätte ich das auch vom
computer gemacht aber jetzt mache ich
mir so ich überlege mir jetzt will ich
die seite machen und was ich ungefähr 1
haben will und dann wenn ich merke jetzt
kommt gerade nichts mehr dann gehe ich
einfach spazieren mit den kindern und
das ist dann zeit die ich als kinderzeit
oder als wenn ich koche als kochzeit
oder wenn ich einfach selber schwimmen
gehen oder so für mich zeit nehme oder
zähle die gehört nicht zu den 15 stunden
aber die ist tatsächlich sehe ich sehr
wichtig um ideen zu generieren
die familie minimiert ihre auslagen
mietkosten für büroräume entfernen
es ist so wenn wir das mitteilen
gegründet haben haben wir als erster
seine lebenskosten reduziert früher
haben wir ja mehr ausgegeben
da haben wir gesehen dass wir sind
glücklicher als fällt uns nicht eine
tolle sachen zu kaufen oder oder viele
sachen so das fällt uns nicht wir sind
glücklicher und weniger und dass das
gibt uns so eine befreiung und eine
kraft auch eine zuversicht und vertrauen
in die zukunft einfach weil wir wir sind
super glücklich mit was wir haben und
leben nicht auf geld das wir nicht haben
ist alles was an die tomaten und gurken
ist alles ein bisschen heißt im kleinen
kellerabteil des mehrfamilienhauses in
basel verpackt maritim kundengeschenke
hier ist die ökonomen und journalisten
ihre eigene chefin bei der zeit oder bei
der süddeutschen zu arbeiten war wie so
ein traum ist ein guter name das ist
ganz viele leute lesen an einer artikeln
aber ich habe gemerkt eigentlich ist der
arbeitsalltag wichtig und der war mir
persönlich war mir zu strukturiert zu
viel im büro sitzen das habe ich gemerkt
dass das für mich nicht so richtig passt
aber es war damals auch noch nicht so
ein richtiges bewusstes ich muss jetzt
weg von hierarchien sondern es war
einfach dass wir was eigenes kunden
wollten auch ihr zweites
unternehmerische standbein sind
solarpanels für den balkon arbeit die
beide glücklich macht
es müssen drei sache der erste ist der
sinn wenn du guckst nach einem jahr
zurück was du gemacht du weißt warum
hast du gemacht hast und dann der zweite
ist dass du arbeiten ganzen flow also
dass du dann arbeiten kannst wenn du
über eine ein guter moment dafür hast du
sie flexibilität und der dritte ist dass
du lernst neue sachen dazu würden
[Musik]
dollar und das immer mit wenn ich das
jetzt so angetan denn er übrigens ist
eigentlich die ihr volk macht uns
glücklich es perfekte idylle ist dass
ich würde sagen ja tatsächlich auf jeden
fall wir lieben das leben so jeden tag
so wie wir uns das vorstellen
wir lieben was wir tun ja wissen warum
wir es tun und und wir haben noch viel
zeit für andere sachen uns sehr wichtig
sehen weil uns die familie die kinder
und das ist ja aber wir haben auch
früher eine tolle jobs sehr interessant
aber jetzt machen wir genau das was wir
für wichtig finden und genau so wie wir
es für richtig halten in führung er wird
wir sind reich in zeit reichen leben
reichen ihnen glück und das ist weiß was
mir wichtig sind ja hat sich sehr
spannend sie bei die zeit mir eins glück
wunder artikel im tages anzeiger über
und tabak merkt das glück ganz viel
licht wahnsinnig aufgeregt sagt mich
verwundert in der kommentarspalte da ist
es richtig zu sagen ich war schon ein
shitstorm sie teilweise unter anderem wo
marco zu tun
stuhr optimierung ungerechtigkeit dass
ihr quasi absichtlich wenige schafften
aber die krankenkasse verbilligungen
überholt
also eigentlich ist für mich der tenno
ich sie ihre liebe das tolles leben für
euch selber aber einige böcke von der
gesellschaft ist das meer ist nicht so
also wir zahlen auf jeden fall mit
unserem unternehmen mehr steuern als wir
verbilligungen vom staat bekommen das
ist ganz klar
und wir zahlen auch gerne steuern also
es ist nicht so dass wir steuern
optimieren und deswegen uns wenig lohn
auszahlen sondern wir zahlen und so
wenig lohn aus weil wir unseren konsum
heruntergeschraubt haben und dann lassen
wir lieber mehr im unternehmen zahlen
darauf dann gewinnsteuer und investieren
das wieder in neue
daneben die die weiter den den planeten
genommen hätte können ja wir sehen dass
er war unsere verbrauch sowie eigentlich
der durchschnittsschweizer erlebt
braucht es drei planeten
die haben wir nicht nur eine plakette
und deshalb mischen wir gern und andere
leute inspiriert zu sehen das weniger
verbrauchern macht glücklicher ist die
einzige lösung die verträglich ist für
die zukunft und ist wunderbar für
rheinbach mit immer mit glück mit tolle
arbeit mit tolle familienzeit und so
weiter
das sind sehr logisch und blick für
viele tests sind für viele ist ein land
wo für ihre provokation wie sie den
wunsch sich professorin für arbeits
markt ökonomie in basel ganz
persönlichen wunsch wenn sie jetzt den
lebensentwurf war oder viel weniger
konsumieren aber dafür auch viel weniger
schaffen wir das ich denke dass es eine
individuelle entscheidung und das ist in
ordnung so
wenn man das natürlich auf die gesamte
gesellschaft überträgt oder auch zu der
frage warum könnten die leute sich auch
daran stören muss man natürlich auch
bedenken es gibt ganz viele leute die
arbeiten für ein sehr geringes
familieneinkommen sehr viele stunden
ja und wenn man ihnen sagt ja arbeitet
doch einfach 15 stunden dann habt ihr
mehr zeit für eure familien sonja und
von was sollen wir leben ja wir können
wir haben nicht stundenlöhne die die
garantieren dass wir von 15 stunden die
woche zum beispiel leben können die
sache ist hat wirklich jeder das
privileg genau die arbeit zu machen die
genau diese bedingungen erfüllt und das
andere ist natürlich auch das konzept
der sozialversicherungssysteme was da ja
so impliziert auch so ein bisschen eben
schmarotzer und nichts einzahlen
wenn alle das machen also auch die die
sich sozusagen von den löhnen leisten
können dann haben wir einfach das
problem ist wird viel zu wenig
eingezahlt ja es wird viel zu wenig
eingezahlt in die systeme und es gibt
mehr leute die potenziell geld daraus
erhalten wie soll das tragfähig sein das
geht nicht irgendwo muss das geld
herkommen
wer sich auch noch interessant ich weiß
gar nicht ob das so viele schweizerinnen
und schweizern hat bietet damit ab
stimme egal wie zum beispiel zum
bedingungslosen grundeinkommen hochkant
abgelehnt
die faire woche hochkommt abgelehnt wenn
den schweizerinnen und schweizer eigene
profil schaffe
also man sieht ganz klar es gibt den
trend dazu dass die leute weniger
arbeiten das hin zum beispiel
arbeitsinhalte viel wichtiger sind als
die bezahlung dass sie auch zunehmend
bereit sind etwas auf einkommen zu
verzichten dafür dass sie zum beispiel
teilzeit schaffen mehr freizeit haben
die work life balance besser stimmt den
trend sieht man ganz klar
aber mein eindruck ist auch wenn ich
verschiedenste abstimmung sehe dass die
schweiz und schweizer durchaus sich sehr
bewusst sind wo ihr wohlstand wo der
wohlstand des landes herkommt und dass
das eine mit dem anderen zusammenhängt
da finde ich aber ein sehr großes
problem dass wohlstand in dem
wirtschaftswissenschaftler wir haben ja
beide auch wirtschaftswissenschaften
studiert einfach immer mit wirtschaft
mit bp mit dem bruttoinlandsprodukt
gleichgesetzt wird das ist natürlich
überhaupt nicht der fall
jetzt wenn ganz viele menschen krank
sind und gesundheitsleistungen in
anspruch nehmen das wächst da wächst das
wirtschaftswachstum sozusagen das ist
gut für die wirtschaft aber eigentlich
ist es schlecht für die gesellschaft
wenn wir kriege haben und und waffen
herstellen dann wächst das wirtschaft
also welche die wirtschaft aber es ist
eigentlich nicht gut für die
gesellschaft wirklich bis der mezquita
in bhutan sowie spielte jetzt das
bruttonationalglück also das hat mit dem
königslutter weist dies dies ohne
grenzen ist ja ganz klar ja ich finde
die politik sollte nicht das
wirtschaftswachstum oder die wirtschaft
und leistungen maximieren sondern das
glück der menschen
und dann wäre zum beispiel so was dass
das viel mehr leute eigentlich 50
prozent arbeiten wollen wahrscheinlich
förderungswürdig ja für uns politisch
ist aber gleichzeitig natürlich nicht so
dass wir irgend jemanden dazu zwingen
wollen oder dazu drängen wollen unser
unser beispiel nachzumachen
aber wir sehen auch dass es viele
menschen inspiriert und da wir wissen
dass dass der planet begrenzt ist und
dass also für unsere kinder sieht die
zukunft im camp im moment wirklich
düster aus oder brennend sage ich mal so
und da ist es für uns ein anliegen
einfach die leute dazu zu inspirieren
den konsum einfach mal zu hinterfragen
weil die wirtschaft wenn sie
wirtschaften zu den männern
da sein und nicht der mensch der für die
wirtschaftliches denken das ist mir zwar
spricht usa betis überhaupt willkommen
da sieht er entweder ich arbeite um
meinen lebensunterhalt zum beispiel zu
finanzieren und dann macht mich das
vielleicht nicht glücklich aber es ist
eine wirtschaftliche notwendigkeit ja
und dann haben wir teile der bevölkerung
finde das vielleicht zutrifft und dann
haben andere die haben sozusagen das
privileg dass sie das nicht müssen dass
sie selber entscheiden können wie viel
möchte ich konsumieren was wie möchte
ich meine arbeit gestalten ist denn das
dass wir wollen dass wir eine gruppe
haben die das nicht kann und eine andere
die das kam aber wie viel konsumieren
das hat jeder also die entscheidung hat
jeder ja natürlich aber jeder an teilt
auch selber was einen glücklich macht
naja gibt leute die macht konsum
glücklich eigentlich also können das für
sich an die wissenschaftlich sie sollen
das wer sich an wissenschaftlich die
psychologen haben sich seit jahrzehnten
haben sie sich damit beschäftigt und
tatsächlich macht konsum nicht wirklich
wirklich sehr gut aus ich sehe vor
wirtschaftlicher sitte zwei drei vier
große fragezeichen wir werden keine
klären aber danke vielmals leber und
sichere marie und ihr die hand kunden
was war ich noch viel vor hat nämlich wo
erfüllt und wo sie in haft ist und sich
sagen dass das stimmt es eigentlich
perfekt oder dass ich so traurig aber
was ist das eigentlich was macht er
seine traumfrau auf der straße
vorarbeiten protektorat den ärzten
psychotherapeuten
[Musik]
eigentlich friedhofsgärtner will die
tour und wenn wir nicht gestört
ich habe eigentlich mein traumjob ich
bin hausarzt und sagt eigentlich alles
[Musik]
traumjob da steht monika mechanisch
verklebt und nach einer betriebs
mechaniker und das ist schon fertig die
heutige zeit also mit dem wissensstand
rötlich wirklich wichtig ist erotik
branche machen also in der tabelle
eigentlich die historikerin zwei aber da
hat sicher viele möglichkeiten müssen
wir immer so richtig israel palästina
galia pilot architekt lag's ja gar kein
traum kindergarten oder so
primarlehrerin schauspieler film drei
dagegen
wenn man durch seine arbeit irgendwie
das gefühl hat dass nur das leben von
anderen menschen besser machen kann
dadurch machte ich mache das gerne
machen aber ich hatte keine chance
bekommen
schauspielerin da sich sehr es gut
stichwort will das döner schon so noch
traum oder nach glamour und alles ist
gerade schauspielerei gesetzt hat der
junge zürcher zoo berlin erklären und
sie als diese folge geschafft
lassen
die junge frau aus der schweiz auf die
djk ich finde eigentlich ist das zehnte
entstanden dass ich mit olga und den
werde ich wieder was in ordnung
wir kriegen immer politik sehen wie sich
gemerkt haben irgendwann das ist gar
nicht das aus auf dem filmset dreht sich
alles um die schweizerin
sie ist der star die erste hauptrolle
der friller heißt aktiv und hat ein
budget von rund eineinhalb millionen
dollar
das ist der ombudsmann der regisseur
drehte drei folgen des horror film
klassiker so die dutzende von millionen
einspielte der amerikaner hat einen
hervorragenden ruf in der branche
für die 28 jährige schweizerin ist die
hauptrolle in seinem neuesten film ein
riesiger karrieresprung
die zürcherin spielt eine schwangere
frau die in einem kloster gefangen
gehalten wird
sabrina kern absolvierte die renommierte
american academy of dramatic arts in los
angeles
viele hollywood-stars haben dort ihr
handwerk gelernt
es ist aufregend jemanden zu entdecken
mit diesem film willich sabrina einem
breiteren publikum präsentieren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sabrina kern lebt seit einem jahr mit
ihrer familie wie sie es nennt ihn los
angeles alle vier wohnen gemeinsam in
einer wg
[Musik]
das sind ihr freund stehe und dessen
schwester go bekannt als indie pop duos
ehemann eve ist profigolfer vier
schweizer die sich an diesem
samstagmorgen einige stunden freizeit
gönnen bevor sie wieder um einen guten
platz im scheinwerferlicht der
traumfabrik kämpfen werden
[Musik]
alle vier arbeiten hart an ihren
karrieren
momentan ist los angeles der mittelpunkt
des universums
doch das kann sich schnell ändern aber
das ist ja wir versuchen werden künstler
ausgestellt
um möglichst günstig zu wohnen teilen
sich die freunde ein kleines haus viel
privatsphäre bleibt da nicht zumal das
haus auch noch übungsraum und tonstudio
ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nach unzähligen würden hat sich sabrina
kern eines der heißbegehrten künstler
visa für schauspieler
[Musik]
der nachteil dieses visums die
schweizerin darf ausschließlich in der
showbranche arbeiten und gerade da ist
der stellenmarkt besonders umkämpft hier
franz ihren ersten job
sie ist ihm bis heute treu geblieben
einmal pro woche arbeitet sie für eine
firma die dinger in einer original aus
flugzeugkabine der airline panam
anbietet sie ist als schauspielerin
angestellt und gibt die methodik kabine
500 franken und mehr bezahlen die gäste
für einen abend in einem stilechten ein
trio aus den 70er jahren
ihr schäfer konnte schnell dass die
tochter eines wird der pass noch ganz
andere qualitäten hat deshalb
koordiniert die schauspieler die
nebenbei auch noch den ganzen ablauf
hinter den kulissen dass ihr die eigene
investitions eigene herz den indisch und
besucher jeder job so egal wille so aus
mir heraus wer suisse passion projekt
als hätte ich das alles ist bald weil
dann schaffen wir für diese hektische
schicht verdient sie gerade einmal 150
franken
und sie ist zufrieden auch das ist eine
realität in hollywood
und jetzt
vor 1
sabrina kern besucht ihre familie in
zürich mutter cissy und vater nicola
betreiben mehrere restaurants eines der
lokale für sabrina schwester melanie
bevor sie sich ins hollywood abenteuer
stürzte studierte sabrina kern an der
universität zürich kommunikation politik
und bwm x3 gericht habe und ich habe sie
versucht zu guttenberg und die freude
dass man sich aber los kaufen
[Musik]
das ist selbst noch ist ja auch
finanziell immer wieder auf die
unterstützung ihrer eltern angewiesen
aber das ist wirklich nur möglich wenn
die ganze familie hinein statt also rein
finanziell so wollte ich überhaupt
probiere ich das gleich zu haben
dann wäre es noch schwieriger unter
druck machen ist aber es hilft sich
nehmen sie das nicht will ich durch mein
echtes aber ich nur zweimal die woche
ganz unabhängig sie und gesteht sie aber
ja
[Musik]
um sich auch auf sängerin im
showbusiness zu empfehlen produziert
sabrina kern ihr erstes musikvideo das
lied hat mit freund stehe und einem
schauspielkollegen geschrieben
die regie macht deren bossen der
regisseur des horrorfilms heute ist die
28-jährige seine chefin
[Musik]
sabrina kerns budget für das musikvideo
beträgt gerade einmal 2000 franken
deshalb hat sie freunde und bekannte aus
der branche zusammen getrommelt die
bereit sind auf ihre gage zu verzichten
auch das ist hollywood ganz viele
menschen werden sich kurz vor dem
durchbruch
für diesen traum opfern sie fast alles
die tonnen gestellt nicht irgendwo
immerhin darauf hollywood sondern sie
sind in zürich wichtig
dies trug in der schweiz und was sie da
macht das finden
am 3
[Musik]
es ist also wirklich vorstellen
schauspielerisch die größte freie
projekte neue jobs aber wo mir die
fallstudien große film mitspielt und es
ist ja eigentlich was dem moment wo
alles möglich ist
was ist noch passiert es ist wirklich
super g und dann noch eine festivals
galt die premieren von velen dass ich
nach erneuten hat sich ein paar jahre
einer halb angezogen und das ist
zulässig und spannende cixi und dann
irgendwann möglichkeit über wofür die
erich fuchs casting zu machen bietet
opera in theorie und drogen es ist ja so
still ist so dass wir nun jeder über
gerät hat vielleicht mal en suite
strucks co das ist schon immer das thema
sie aber ich war immer einfach für mich
wichtig wird ein wichtiger grund hat zum
zug wo ich wollte nicht so krones habe
mich zurück geholt wie glamourös ist das
leider tatsächlich wenn es denn hätte in
hollywood sehr oft gar nicht also so wie
mir jetzt gehabt habe ich sie überhaupt
kann gleich mal so und das gegenteil
während jetzt nachdem hooligans limit
einbaut zimmer grund also mit vier mann
das ist mein gefühl war natürlich noch
aus dem film eine hauptrolle hat für die
woche ist plötzlich fühlt sich sehr
bemüht sich um ein und bist du ganz
wichtig aber eben auch komische film
fährt ist gottes gott so vom mega dass
man das gefühl hat er ist die richtige
person auf der welt für woche zu wieder
interessiert
also die höchste ja ja die vision song
contest regie und dann stoppte so die
handtasche spielen wir uns nicht so dass
nur spannend oder ich wäre froh etwas
macht was macht glücklich und bitte
schauspielerei und auch bier oder
musikhaus kirstein richtig glücklich
sind ganz oben nach ob ich das schaffe
aber eigentlich die wenigsten genau wie
macht man den job trotzdem für mich ist
immer einfach kreativ sieht also mich
gelöscht hatte mal unbedingt so die
einzelnen erfüllen klassisch schön und
die besatzung bitte machen aber kreation
war so blöd das ziel also dass du
überhaupt haus vor dem legalen zu viele
fälle wo bei mir ist das anders
ich finde jetzt zum beispiel mich macht
das ganze katia all die castings gar
noch mehr glücklich zu machen also im
sinnvoll es ist macht mich total nervös
die castings gar nicht findet das
malbuch sagte kruse weber gehört vor 100
oder ist das nein und das ist es so ich
habe auch die kritiker wieder als dass
man das trage nun mal so dass und wie
muss ich mir das nicht vorstellen dass
ich meistens
warum gerade jetzt nach völlig neue peas
und immer wartet quasi fertig wurde
kommt und dass sie aus nicht einfach mit
mich was ist preis bezahlt wenn wir auf
den sohn jobs setzt wie du jetzt also
zur sicherheit wurden schweizer zum
beispiel anhand derer muss man auch audi
wollte also sicherheit dass zum beispiel
dass man echten monat soundso viel
verdient das hat man hier und und mit
dem muss man sich abfinden oder über
wasser man weiß einfach zukunft des
hauses mit plötzlichem verbucht und dann
guatelli
aber noch muss das ihr nach dem man bach
setzt das einfach nicht mehr heraus nach
verona ich ganz viel wo immer einen
trick tätig sind wirklich existenziell
werden oder als ich meine dass oder
durchführen die rastaner oder sind es
die älteren war unterstützt oder wie
machen er hat sicher unterstützen
das war so aber ich muss dem händler in
corona ja bei die glück dass man immer
trotzdem hat keine mieterschaft halt
nicht ich zum beispiel nicht unbedingt
nur auf den prüfern ich wollte sabine
stahl aber ich unterrichte viel spaß
spiel und gute wetterlage online hat
auch felix unterrichtet klugen und yoga
und mannschaften aus dassow unterstützen
eltern vertrauen in restaurants offen
und ach ja und das macht ja für alles
gute danke für das interview und jetzt
einmal zweig sie wo sie brennen was sie
machen und jetzt muss man sich
vorstellen was wäre denn umgekehrt chips
wo man gar nicht wir machen oder also
was während brown jobs
als traumjob vermutlich aktuell für die
pflege oder einfach so ein fußball job
wo einiges klargemacht wo schlagzahl
tisch wo stressig ist ohne anna handick
zahnarzt ausstellen chemie war gebaut
fit in der bank war ich früher machen
[Musik]
metzkes in meinem büro sei werde jetzt
für mich sehr schwierig es ist ein
wichtiger job aber ich kann es für mich
jetzt nicht vorstellen wie müllabfuhr
lagen für sich mit der woche bevor es
mit microsoft suche schon für sich ein
förderband stürzt in excel-tabellen
ausfüllen im büro nicht begründet
nach passieren der ganztag um honig
machen
na ja so schwierig ist das netz in der
pflege denke ich zurzeit auf jeden fall
was man so hört
[Musik]
sie mir menschen überhaupt geschaffen
zum schafe oder weil sony bewohner das
wetter klären mit der philosophin und
sternstunde moderatorin barbara bleisch
[Musik]
als philosophin es nämlich sehr wohl die
frage macht aber glücklich ist das
eigentlich es formiere gesetzt sowie der
neuzeit fragen oder ist diese frage wohl
schon früher man beschäftige holte er in
acht und wie ich würde schon sagen
stehenden neuere frage seid natürlich
philosophen und philosophie immer
interessiert wie man ein gutes
gleichgewicht zwischen arbeit und muße
freizeit aber arbeit ist immer ähnlich
sieht das muss halt sie und sich gut
wenn man da wirklich weniger machen aber
das arbeitsfeld glücklich machen das
innere neue idee will ich finde es auch
interessant also die frage macht aber
glücklich bedeutet einen forschen sie
sind glücklich machen erwarte mir
eingeschlichen
also ich würde doch zuerst einmal
umdrehen und sagen was man erwarten
könnt ist dass arbeit nicht unglücklich
macht und ich finde wald gesehen wäre
das schon ein riesen gewinnen und den
fortschritt es geht viel
arbeitsverhältnis verklagen ist
unstrittig sind wo menschen in ihrer
würde verletzt werden wo liegt wirklich
lieder tvo und die wenigen gefährlichen
arbeitsbedingungen vorher statt und
darum der anspruch dass arbeitsminister
nicht unglücklich macht glaube ich ist
ein absolut übertrieben allerdings
krediten und da schon etwas mehr
erwartet
und mach einfach zu sagen es gibt es
eine idee von work kissen also über die
idee testarbeit ein so sehr muss fühlen
dass sie ganz der identität wird als
vollkommen ausfüllt und das gefällt
natürlich auch im arbeitgeber will
ordnet nehmen die wo sagt definieren die
über ihre arbeit sind natürlich sehr
leistungsfähige setzt einen arm bis zum
montag
[Musik]
spannend ist tatsächlich was mir
überhaupt unterart bestimmt auch im
vorfeld der sentiment gemerkt mir redet
immer nur vor lohnt wenn mir vor arbeit
redet ist das entwaffnung nein und das
ist ganz wichtigen aspekt ganz viel
arbeitet die ganze sogenannte work
hausarbeit familienarbeit quartier für
kranke menschen vor ort hörige für
ältere personen vor hinter und so wie
der ganze bereich rechnen oft nicht zu
arbeiten zur wohne jetzt von kairo
krättli sie aber nicht entlohnt wird das
heißt man tendenz der zusatzbezeichnung
wohnen lohn bringt und das ist verkürzt
ich habe natürlich sage ja gut was
bringt zu hause einrichten von der
ganzen care arbeitet als arbeitet oder
die sogar gezahlt ja was es bringt das
natürlich ein hochwertig von dem ganzen
sektor schwester regel genauso und
wertschätzen und eine klinik als geht
die schöne geschichte oder drei
steinmetze die steine zur tracht sagt
erste seit ich bei hauenstein der 2
seit ich schaffen unter denen und
betritt die seit ich trage beats umbau
vor der kathedrale
und weil er die schachtel glücklich
steht wahrscheinlich die dritte wie man
immer das gefühl ich habe trage zu einem
großen ganzen
wenn es um große ganze die 13 ganze hat
manager in the flag brief aber viele
vorteile sind im moment nicht besonders
glücklich zum beispiel da am zürcher
kinderspital
noch ist es ruhig
die spätschicht hat erst begonnen knapp
neun stunden dauert eine schicht mit
kurzen pausen dazwischen mittwoch bc
sport das heißt jeden tag vom wird lockt
zwar bis am 11
und jetzt [ __ ] horny und die harmonie
nacht auf einem kinde notfall zu
arbeiten ist wie hochleistungssport
extrem anspruchsvoll bei höchster
konzentration
[Musik]
umso wichtiger dass sich ruhe und
arbeitszeiten die waage halten
doch im alltag eines kinder notfalls
häufig gar nicht machbar
[Musik]
und das nicht nur das ist wahrscheinlich
eben mit springer oder der grund jeder
dass es wenige oder auch heutigen
springen und auch der heimische
forschung ist ja einfach zu wenig los in
ihren verträgen wir kompensieren
ich muss doch es gab immer liegen wir es
gab einfach zu gut für mehrere schichten
zu mir springen die pflegefachfrauen und
männer in dem kinder notfall die ersten
die das kranke kind ziehen und reagieren
müssen
die verantwortung ist hoch
er muss sich an alle lehrer erschossen
der notfall fühlt sich die betten sind
alle belegt die pflegefachleute betreuen
mehrere kinder gleichzeitig
[Musik]
stimmt im 19
ich bin jetzt einfach - rot-rot nicht
arbeitet sie nach viel licht sieht tico
wo muslime mit antibiotika ist original
zugzwang
das haben schon andere chess classic
wirklich leid ich anatomisches heißt
serie von bin ich verantwortlich so
immer wieder läutet und das macht im
schnitt kommen täglich 120 kinder auf
den notfall
das sind 45.000 im jahr bei klein julius
ist mittlerweile klar er hat eine
schwere akute bronchitis
[Musik]
die arbeitsbelastung wird immer größer
bei praktisch gleichem personalbestand
das kann langfristig nicht aufgehen auf
der schicht sind heimreise umfassten die
frage und warum gemeint war einfach mit
seinem gefährlich jetzt eigentlich nur
noch darum mit renault betrieben immer
wir können die leute mich wenn ich meine
braut blogger michael ihn nur noch knapp
über wochen und das macht unbedingt dass
ich das was mir macht im moment eben
einfach völlig flagge und bei einer
schicht aus und darf gott sei dank
verschiedenen passiert ist es nicht so
schön zu schaffen
sie will heldstab film gesehen
kinderspital zürich jetzt wie mir
minister vielen europa league wahren
ängste dass die situation so krass wie
die uns wird nichts oder gott während
hinter einer so straff sehr
situationsbedingt mit friede und und
frieden grundsätzlich ist ja tatsächlich
eine gewünschte profis geht für mich
weil ich mit ließ karim prof und ich
muss sagen ich als großen teil 2 5
prozent und wird auf keinen fall madoff
verordnet ich finde es sehr dass er dazu
standen häufig knapp blüten sind häufig
am rande müssen häufig groß unterstützte
mir sind häufig am limit uns noch mehr
also nachmittag auf dem meeraner häufig
sehr emotional also mehr ganz viele
bilder
ich erwarte ja häufig wir etwas mühe
sich den anderen klappte ganz ich
ständig auf futter politiker hatte
schlussendlich da heißt und in
deutschland geworden
aber wahrscheinlich kann wichtige profis
machen so schön dass mir die hand
das stimmt alles unter fremder es ist
vor allem die personal für andere
funktioniert alles schriftlich aber man
macht einfach ein extrem reizvoll
aufgabe war es aufgabe werden damals
verschafft könntet machen für uns wäre
es tatsächlich viel entspannter
doch immerhin zweiter gesprochen
von sigrid beer beschäftigt mich genauso
zukunftsfähige gesellschaft wie
entwickelt sich david stars jetzt zivil
hält da gibt es doch entwickelt aber so
richtig kennt ja ganz klar
natürlich hofft der technologischen
seite trat stichwort digitalisierung wo
viel diskutiert worden ist wo viele
jetzt momentan verhandelt wird wird im
umfang von spittal und eine idee oder
vision wie statt sachlich dass man
einfach repetitive oft aber genau da wo
sie frisst der traumpartner damit sie
sich mehr und außerdem kümmern wo die
wertschätzung eigentlich stattfindet und
wo der mensch nicht ersetzbar ist
gegenüber der maschine
und so geht's hoffnung aber es gibt auch
viele kritische element immer sagen ja
was wäre die kritische element also
fleck roboter sei es still um ihn mal
wieder gehört oder ganze bandbreite das
pfarrbüro waterloo zum beispiel eine
ältere patient haus führt zum start ganz
natürlich weiter dann gibt es roboter
eingesetzt werden
und die ethische schwieriger zum
beispiel als so streichen roboter
entwickelt wurde sind die sind in japan
für demenzkranke genau das sind herzlich
seehöhe die bewegt sich spitze und da
haben wir jetzt natürlich zum einen
sagen das geht überhaupt nicht dass man
ein mensch mit der maschine quasi
koppelt allerdings sind die klinische
studie zeigt dass die realität an
übernehme ganz worden damit das rennen
körperlich besser gold schwieriger punkt
jetzt muss man einerseits aus
gesellschaft entscheiden möchten dass
grundsätzlich zu oder wir natürlich den
punkt wenn die versicherte ich bin eine
patientenverfügung doch wenn ich eine
stimme so ganz da bin und es tut mir gut
wenn ich doppelte streissler und dann
lerne ich das zu
[Musik]
ich stehe fragt macht aber glücklich
dann auch wieder ausdruck von luxus
problem oder so first world problem
spitzenschuh zu ganz vielen menschen auf
der welt ist es schon als riesenglück
wenn es überhaupt schaffen der
lohnarbeit spricht die existenzgrundlage
sichere ihr die familie durchbringen
tool gaga zahlen schul und fahren können
und so weiter und ich finde auch dass
nämlich immer wieder bewusst und lässt
sich die kämmerin ist unbehagen wenn man
von den first world problem redet und
das luxusproblem ist beruhigt euch doch
mal alberte der gesellschaften und jede
gesellschaft bringt die geeignete zwei
mechanismen schwierigkeiten hervor
und wenn man so überlegen wie viele
menschen es burn-out und depressionen
hand oder als sogenannte bullshit jobs
und machen wie das der david gruber
nennt dieses unendlich sind eher die
bürokratische arbeit was ist mit mir
identifizieren was ja gar nichts gefühl
hat dass es einen unterschied macht ob
überhaupt aber die arbeit macht dann
muss ich sagen das sind wirkliche
problem intern schnell ganz unbedingt
ernst
[Musik]
ich habe schon sehr viel kürzer frage
wenn dass sie es aber glücklich macht
und eine studie wurde den heißt es unter
anderem dass sie es aber tut wenn sie
fußt sinn macht wenn man verantworten
könnte über neue und eine gewisse
zukunftsperspektive hat aber die andere
studie werden er trifft das ist
eigentlich schon verschlangen man
einfach immer gute team schafft ein
fairer lohn hätte und die
arbeitskolleginnen und kollegen
sicherlich ice arbeitet macht denn
unglücklich weil es eben immer hält
[Musik]
andreas knoche 59 jahre alt arbeitslos
seit drei jahren
er ist ingenieur elektrotechnik mit
einem nachdiplomstudium als
betriebswirtschaft und hat
jahrzehntelang in führungspositionen
gearbeitet mehrheitlich im ausland bis
er entlassen wurde
es gibt plötzlich weg und es gibt
weniger gute gott sei dank sie die wände
geburt nicht so häufig aber die gibt es
und das ist auch immer so dass ich mich
frage was eine frau gebracht dass es
mehr recht hat oder was halte ich ein
anderes machen da hatte ich selber merke
dass sie die richtigkeit dieser tage
unter community gewehre mit da muss man
umgehen ist das aber wichtig dass man
die strukturen tag durch festhalten dass
man einfach sagen wir mit dir und die
profis überzeugen dass wir komplett
falsch muss erst mal eine gewisse
struktur bietet in seinem haus in
bellach ist andreas knoche selten allein
er hat zwei erwachsene kinder tochter
tamara kommt häufig zu besuch
als ihr vater arbeitslos wurde wohnte
sie als studentin noch im elternhaus
moment wissen wir das
doch mit neuem studio nahmen 104 nach
kann ich gleich bleibend nur
unterstützen
mini unterstützt agno richtete auch
nicht immer das wofür täterin einfach
ist das meine ich in la paloma plötzlich
stille
und das ist negativ
wie ihr bruder matthias ging sie
zunächst davon aus dass der vater rasch
wieder arbeit findet beide tauschten
sich zwei jahre bekam knochen
arbeitslosengeld dann würde er aus
gesteuert er lebt heute ohne einkommen
und bezieht keine sozialhilfe sonst
müsste er das haus verkaufen
matthias kann als medizinstudent nichts
beisteuern
aber die familie hält zusammen auch wenn
sich das kompakte gerät als kurz und der
partie war alleine sie die hits der
schwedischen
langzeitarbeitslosigkeit eine enorme
belastung für die betroffenen und ihre
angehörigen
heidi knuchel hat ihre stelle von 60 auf
100 prozent aufgestockt um den
einkommensverlust ihres mannes
aufzufangen
sie möchte sich in diesem film nicht
äußern
[Musik]
ein großer tag für andreas knoche er hat
es geschafft von einem tag auf den
anderen fand er eine neue stelle pensum
40 prozent
es ist die beziehung von jobs selber ist
wahnsinnig spannend aber natürlich jetzt
noch tätig sind das aber sie war ist der
lage der ausländer
[Musik]
knoche ist für eine teamsitzung
angereist er arbeitet neu für skills
onyx ein startup-unternehmen dass die
schweizer berufslehre ins ausland
exportieren will seine aufgabe ist es
partner firmen im in und ausland zu
finden die qualifiziertes personal
brauchen und darum in die berufsschulen
investieren
wie das jetzige nun andere bauten oder
der neue chef schenkt knochen vertrauen
xml standard flexibilität und eine von
der große vorteil ein krimineller
unter müssen fokussiert und sogar
flexibler ja immer das nicht installiert
aber nicht das ist es auch schwieriger
befinden wo ich diese idee die
konstellation in der post oder was er
gemacht hätte
speziell und und das ist gut denn da ist
einfach die größe vorwiegend aus sehr
gut die erfahrung aus der wirtschaft
das findet der anwender einfach so
[Musik]
also muss ich sagen absolut top ich
würde das entspannen das ist ganz neues
gebiet dort internationale brot
streichen auch nicht foto aber von mein
arbeitsgebiet ist das ganz anders
weil das ist eigentlich super auf der
andere sind natürlich
gegen voreilige thomas siek deutschland
was sie gut wenn wir jetzt das video
mittelbar und unmittelbar einfluss trend
ist das aber in dem moment der zu
verfügen
aber das ist natürlich auch
pensionskassen entsprechend lieder die
löcher in der vorsorge sind nicht mehr
zu stopfen
er wird auch nach der pensionierung noch
an den folgen der arbeitslosigkeit
leiden lebenslänglich das war vor drei
jahren
heute heißt es zurück auf feld eins
[Musik]
andreas knoche ist wie der arbeitslos
die stelle bei skil sonics hat er nach
eineinhalb jahren wieder verloren
ein strategiewechsel in der akquisition
war der grund fast nahtlos fand er als
freier mitarbeiter eine anschlusslösung
um kurz darauf wegen corona wieder auf
der straße zu stehen irgendwo zu
häufigem mehr denn im bekanntenkreis
nicht wo man sich trifft wenn sie
natürlich bedeute deutlich malente be
und er ist vor der schlimmsten momente
sieht aber genau dann wenn der qualität
über die arbeit über den berg runter und
in der musik ich habe freunde überlegen
ist auf der anderen seite gibt es
eigentlich sollte es sogar möglich offen
knoche lebt nach wie vor ohne einkommen
wegen seiner selbstständigkeit hat er
kein recht auf arbeitslosenentschädigung
[Musik]
die vorselektion
stan grund eigentlich auch die erfahrene
kandidatin sarah knappik sie das ist
durchaus so soll in drei jahren wird
andreas knoche pensioniert seinen
ruhestand hat er sich anders vorgestellt
die finanziellen reserven sind
aufgebraucht ohne arbeit was man braucht
ist und dieser musste und wie es bis zur
pension alaba
[Musik]
ich war ja beim think tank mit dem
leiter mit dem stefan sigrist ihr
beschäftigt mich genauso
zukunftsforscher oder woher gesellschaft
wie entwickelt sich das kann man noch
mal schnell zurück zum andreas knoche
mehr diskutieren über rentenerhöhungen
immer um es in die st bewusster werden
all jene länger scharf auf die ansicht
immer mehr liegt wie er jetzt einfach
mehr knapp 50 ende der fahnenstange
es stellt dies gar nicht begonnen das
sind persönliche kräfte aber zu meiner
kamera zum glück für länger und dänische
seitlich naheliegend dass man halt bei
banalen geschafft und wie sie sagen
auf der anderen seite hat die tendenz
ist das hat aber weniger mit der
tatsache dass generell ältere
darstellbar sind sondern vielmehr
mitgestaltet von der sozialversicherung
dass unsere betrag geht dass man schon
aufpassen wo man glaubt möglichst viel
stunde möglichst leistungsfähige
speicher und es geht natürlich ganz viel
art solche studien zeigen ältere
mitarbeiter könnten und würden grosse
betrag könne leichter aber wir müssen
sie den vielleicht über die modalitäten
auch dank hat zum beispiel muss eine so
sieht das der lohn immer wieder rufe
gott sondern vielleicht kann man sagen
ich bin größer und irgendwann wieder
blitzsauber das macht attraktiver zum
ältere lied ich stelle mir easy stell
ich zur arbeit verändern wenn wir diese
wertschätzung anderer neuzugang robert
ist ein ganz elementarer bestandteil im
alltag vieler erwartet dass sich der
vergangenheit zog sie das ist die
zukunft also grundsätzlich glaube ich
spricht sehr vieles dafür dass man nicht
alle welt arbeitslose und dass man nicht
sagt prozent foto rüd die jobs verlieren
sondern das eigentlich eher das passiert
was mit der vergangenheit bei anderen
industriellen revolution auch sie hätten
einfach neue jobs dazukommen aber alle
tiere übergegangen sind immer mit diesen
ort hip hops nennt man das
verbunden das heißt das wird gar die
wartet vorübergehend bis sich das stellt
die arbeit verlieren und das heißt aber
wie befehlen ein anderes ausrichtung auf
ein ort über drei lange nicht sondern
das braucht mehr über die stadt leiste
das baby so hück geboren werden gesperrt
da irgendeine mal traf er lerne was
hüten oder gibt und glück geht es aber
auch zur sache die blieben stabil oder
sind im vr zum beispiel andere absolut
arbeiten auch ich vor in reale hektische
welt nehmen dass ihr werdet krank und
das ist ein große illusion wenn man
glaubt digitalisierung heißt das
haptische und die realität werkstatt im
geteilter dritter einmal für die schweiz
redet ist das duale bildungssystem mit
der lehre mit der handwerk extrem
wichtig und friedliche zukunft noch
wichtiger
will man aber beide seiten
zusammenbringen und ich glaube ein
zentrale innovationsfaktor führendes
land wie die schweiz ist aber nicht
zwingend mit dem silicon valley in
wettbewerb treten oder mit der chinese
das sind wir nicht nur groß aber wir
hohe kompetenz in der wissenschaft in
der mechanik elektronik aber hinter das
handwerk leandra wolfisberg ihr job hat
zukunft die 16-jährige wird malerin
annina mutter die ihre heimat ist in
digitale welt hoher besuch oder so das
heißt wir möchten dass straßen trifft
gegen die top-teams in online gesät den
bin ich dann einen text zu schreiben und
dann geht das online
annina mutter ist nachhaltigkeits
bloggerin die outfits ihrer mode
shootings beispielsweise sind fair
produziert oder neu genäht aus second
hand mode mit dem man ich mache und ich
glaube wenn wir so moment dann kann man
so oft traumjob beschrieben
glücksmomente bei der arbeit mit
fotografin nicole i
[Musik]
die welt des 16 jährigen lena wolfisberg
ist aktuell eine großbaustelle in borsch
tragen wenn es extrem heiß und extrem
windig aber mit großer würde sagen es
gewähren job sache wo man nicht so gerne
macht und liebe macht aber im großen und
ganzen ja glück blocken
nürnberg hat auch in zukunft goldenen
boden denn sie und ihre kollegen werden
in absehbarer zukunft nicht durch
roboter ersetzt sagt der schweizerische
baumeisterverband in ihrer virtuellen
welt wachse das bedürfnis mit den händen
in der erde zu buddeln sagt
nachhaltigkeits bloggerin amina mutter
mittlerweile schottischen schöne momente
knies jetzt für mich also trotz der 30
zumindest bei mir das doch nicht dass
wir in so viel zu hell
aber ich muss nicht jede einzelne
momente voller und und immer und
überhaupt sondern mäßig den messer aber
aussehen dass man wirklich oft 1
genießen
annina mutter ist schauspielerin und hat
einen bachelor in design management
und das mit dem boden das licht erlischt
weiterentwickelt sogar 12 13 jahren
die meisten sind stolz wenn sie erst mal
nur geht wenn es an der können und
märkten charaktere dass es eigentlich
gut zu mir passt und dass ich das gut
mache
das hätte einen auf den produktmix sache
einfach nicht so ernst wie vielleicht
andere und also müssen wir einiges
gewöhnt von batterie von mir immer
geschafft und man merkt einfach dass
merz teamplayer sind und fünf mitglieder
zusammen schaffen
und das kv ist frische milch macht's
langweilig also ich habe da mit profil
und hoffe sagte vierte sieg das
film-team so internationale sei
allgemein so gut für dich ist es nicht
viel besser und mittlerweile so fest auf
mangel sondern auf qualität durch meinen
ethischen roth großen teil interessiert
dort sachlich für nachhaltigkeit und
stehen für den brand wir sind aber
interessant wenn du mit mir von geoffrey
willis wenn ich mit china scharf denn
auch ziemlich sicher das zielpublikum wo
ähnliche werte wie sie um den rand ihres
produkt sehr interessant platzieren
das ist ziemlich blöd zusammenarbeit mit
der sbb mit dem parkhof dazu war also
sich doch in glücksgefühlen wenn sie
jetzt sauber den xanthi eine schöne
kleider und so glaube ich kann das ganze
auch schon durchschaut und muss leider
mitteilen dass fame und sichtbarkeit
nötige glück sind und ich kann meine
knut beispiel wo ganz viele berühmte
menschen worüber genau zeigen dass das
nicht erschließen zum glück ist
ganz überrascht
[Musik]
mir hat mal rauf und runter und scott
golder woche ist kickboxen und das thema
boni also mache ich habe mich relativ
hoch sei gewiss so einen mann sie zu dir
passt ja lustig lustig europa schaffen
zudem froh es funktioniert mit zu
vertrauen
ich bin ich sie die täter nicht aus dass
christen so offen dass gerade ich so
weil ich nie geredet haben
ich mache alles gesagt und ich
kommuniziert ist auch wenn das
tatsächlich mini wert sind also ich mach
das und ich mit der salbe absitzt also
schon ab dass sie zur kamera
grundsätzlich ist so dass wir alles wo
mensch tier nicht respektiert für mich
nur den pfosten
ich möchte mich nicht weiter errichtet
und dann natürlich das schon gar nicht
bewerben andere die arbeit mache ich so
mini ort und wie es probieren besser zu
machen oder beitrag zu leisten dass der
planet wissen ja ich glaube das buch ich
mich sogar irgendwie nach dem probieren
vielleicht auch für positive laden
sondern inspirieren
dann gib mir das in diesem sinn
allein unter lauter männern
arbeitsalltag für die 16 jährige laura
wolfisberg
[Musik]
die grünen sagen ja was macht ihr da
rein hoffe wenn wir machen einfach
normal der besch was macht denn wir
akzeptiert aber jetzt wo es ja ich sind
schon
ich finde so ein großer teil in imbaba
ich mache zu unglücklich möglich gemacht
ich brauche besonders minimal zumindest
erfüllt und ich mir gern zu investieren
für das kann nämlich unterschiedlich sie
und ich kann mir gut vorstellen dass das
für mich aber besonders liebt sie ich
komme ich viel verschiedene sache
begeistern und das ist jetzt gut im
moment vom branche auch von außen wie
sony jetzt ich bin sehr kribbelt es ist
eine körperliche person ich bin mit
bewegung aufgewachsen mit kunstturnen
und schafft kam herr dass ich dann auch
mal das praktikum von bio hof gemacht
das heißt alle somit optisch ist und
eben so halt eben virtuell und baute bis
mit einer hand oder so sehr gut
vorstellen
17 und 23
ich finde es richtig dass radfahrer im
glücklich gemacht wenn wir wieder gute
küche zum schlafen und sich freut
dennoch ein guter sich immer verbessern
und ich auskühlen erfolg basiert auf dem
dass man mit dem man auch zu verschaffen
wenn man selbst aber zeigen wo man macht
wenn für job gefunden worden ist wohl
richtig richtig glücklich macht sie im
rundgang mit der frage passantinnen und
passanten
wie müsste der job müssen sie sehen
heute finden der ihr eine kombination
zwischen lehrerin und couch verkäufer
also irgendwas mit leuten zu tun haben
irgendwas wo man seine ruhe haben kann
irgendwas drin irgendwas draußen eher
genervt ist laufen nur mami sein dürfen
[Musik]
das café wo man basteln konnte ein
großer fan muss mache was beiden braig
festzulegen so richtig lief lag sie will
kann sie wo man hat eine ferien immer
wird und somit länger justine unglück
schwer ist wenn ihr schiff mit rot ob
das fahrzeug geschossen und 45 2 und
drehte schaffte das könnte so eine
idealvorstellung sie stephan sigg
richtig da realistisch schaffen ihre
zukunft november sind ja wenn der
generellen einige wurde zukunftsforscher
und der technologietreiber gelabert 1
durch user dann ist es tatsächlich so
dass den trotter und maschinen wieder
alles abnehmen und internet ein paar
konter bis leise und so aber ich glaube
das ist nicht so ganz realistisch und
unter umständen angeordnete so
wünschenswerte wieder sucht er blickt
mache viel weniger schafft also ich
glaube man muss vielleicht einen schritt
zurück machen und zu dem zurück was
quasi mit dem glück steht und dabei
derzeit wird selbst bestimmt nichts tun
mit selbstwirksamkeit mit der gießkanne
machen und ihr könnt mir durchaus noch
andere tätigkeiten vorstellen das auch
nicht machen aber das hatte er gesagt
mit produktivitäts tools hatte mit der
pistole wo man bis neues erschafft
wir sind ja und die vorstellung von der
ganze tag am strand legen und so was
passiert nach ihr glaube ich dem auch
das nicht glücklich und gesetze aber
ehrlich hinzu rückt wenn sie spielt sie
nur die eigentlichen tätigkeit wo eine
aufgabe ist und ich glaube es liegt in
der natur von mensch dass man aber die
aufgabe hat und diese versucht
ob das jetzt bezahlt die apathisch oder
eine andere tätigkeit aber das kann man
sicherlich reden aber quasi ein aufgab
ist aber die dem sicherlich ganz
zentrales element für zweiter haltung
für glück und für das was man möchte
also deutschland ganz vieles in bewegung
und ich bin sicher die gedanke ein
branchen traudi einiges ausgelöst sie
nimmt mich wunderbar aber macht sie euch
glücklich oder stellen die nur auf
position dass er sehr glücklich machen
muss nicht bis ganz anderes im leben
kommentar gerne doch diesen kanal
abonniere dem leben rufen laufenden
danken wir mal für das interesse